some 250,000 people are still evacuating
from the barrier islands off the North
Carolina coast the Outer Banks are
vulnerable to a potentially deadly storm
surge that could reach up to 13 feet
above the ground in some places and the
area may get as much as thirty five
inches of rain that's more than ever
recorded in the state mark Strassmann is
there he's in Kitty Hawk North Carolina
mark good morning good morning on this
street facing the Atlantic all these
houses are on stilts for a reason one
lifelong resident told me in the past
storm surge on this street has been
higher than 15 feet standing here I
would be standing ten feet underwater so
there's a reason why all these homes are
mostly deserted riding out Florence here
could be a deadly mistake the rush to
prepare for Florence is in full swing in
Nags Head Mathews Campbell spent the day
boarding up his surf shop anything
that's not nailed down or connected
together flying into the building and I
live upstairs so all those concerns
double over for myself residents filled
and stacked sandbags to protect homes
and businesses from the threat of
floodwaters while tourists listening to
dire warnings from officials rush to
evacuate gas stations were busy with
people filling up before filing out
we're going to go to Virginia Beach's on
vacation we hate to lose it all tourist
Dan and Cynthia Howe hope they can
salvage some of their vacation that's
been derailed by Florence but I wanted
to get off pass the bridge before we get
in big trouble you know and then we get
behind if other people evacuating
emergency officials staggered the
evacuation orders to avoid bottleneck
situations and the bridge connecting
Kittyhawk to the mainland is now a
one-way road off the island deputies
posted here will stop anyone tried to
get on to the barrier island except
emergency crews Eddie Stewart was on
vacation from Richmond Virginia
unfortunately Florence had other plans
for us we have to try to come back to
try again another hopefully OBX will
actually
still be here the governor of North
Carolina has issued what he called a
first-of-its-kind mandatory evacuation
order for the Outer Banks the reason its
first of its kind
Noora is that it is the storm is so
worrisome the order came from the state
and not from local officials mark I know
you've covered a number of hurricanes
good to have your reporting down there
thank you Mark